you know we have to be out there we have
to be experimenting we have to be
looking for that which makes us pick I
think when people start to get lost
that's when their lives are grossly
inconsistent with their values that I
think about that a lot of people say
does it bother you when people
underestimate you and I say I welcome
people to underestimate me she's an
entrepreneur former reality TV
personality and mom she's currently
executive vice president in charge of
development and acquisitions at the
Trump Organization and sits on the board
of 100 women in hedge fund she also has
their own line of fashion items
including clothing handbags and shoes
which are available in major u.s.
department stores she's Ivanka Trump and
here's my take on her top ten rules for
success rule number one is my personal
favorite and make sure to stick around
all the way to the excellent special
bonus clip also as the bunk is talking
if you said something that really
resonates with you please leave it in
the comments below put quotes around it
as well but other people can be inspired
as well enjoy
I look around at my girlfriends and my
my guy friends and they're in jobs that
they don't really have a lot of growth
potential in that they're not passionate
about and I think if we're ever going to
make little decisions has to be at this
point in our lives you know we have to
be out there we have to be experimenting
we have to be looking for that which
makes us pick and I think a big part of
that evolution for me was really summer
jobs working and making sure to actually
you know get into the world and try
different things and eliminate those
which is as useful eliminating those
career paths that you're not interested
in as it is you know doing things that
that do interest you I think just being
bold and and taking risks when you're
young is so important because I can't
imagine working the hours that I do if I
didn't fundamentally love it I think
that's the difference between somebody's
successful and somebody that's extremely
successful somebody that's good and
somebody that's exceptionally good
there's the level of drive which
directly stems from passion I think the
only way to build confidence is through
trial and error I think when you're
young one of the challenges is that
you're insecure about knowing nothing
and you think people expect you to have
all the answers now as a 34 year old I'm
okay with not having all the answers I
recognize there's a lot I don't know and
I own that and I love that and it makes
me curious and helps me continue to grow
that's why I always tell people just get
out and do things you have to learn
through trial and error and you have to
just try and every time you try
something you get a little bit more
experience a little bit more wisdom you
build a little bit more confidence that
all of you young people just get out
there start doing things take risks just
just try you have successes and they
start out small you're given something
to do and you do it well and then you do
the next thing well and the next thing
well and the next thing well and
suddenly you feel good about yourself
and you have the confidence to set the
bar higher in terms of
steps and goals and you know I think
that part of why I'm very ambitious I'm
an entrepreneur I think first and
foremost having my own business
obviously growing the Trump footprint
around the globe but but I think it's
always starts with the little things you
do early in your career that lay the
foundation for you ultimately to achieve
those bigger dreams I ask all the women
that I interview can women truly have it
all because when someone looks at your
life from the outside in your mother
your wives your real estate developer
you have a full time job but you have
another full-time job because you also
have a very successful clothing and
accessories business so it seems like
you have it all but do you think women
really can have it all I think it's a
very difficult question and it's one
that I try not to answer for other
people because I think by its nature
what is having it all mate it means
different things to different people
you know for me it's very important to
have a family but it's also very
important to be professionally for
fiddle for some people one of those is
important and the other is and so you
know I think you have to figure out what
your priorities are and in life are and
then architect your life around those
priorities I think when people start to
get lost it's when their lives are
grossly inconsistent with their values
and
and their core priorities so for me you
know at the end of every week I sort of
do a self-assessment of and I spend my
time in the right way
was I where I needed to be you know if
there are some days it's okay to not be
home for dinner I have a big deal my
priority may be that for that moment of
time but I also know if my child ever
gets sick if anything happens well there
goes every other priority so I think
it's always a balance and you just have
to do the best we can do I think as a
leader I think you I think you want to
be a benevolent one I think you want to
inspire your team and obviously having
them respect to you doesn't mean they
ain't that you know you're soft you're
weak but I think being kind and
thoughtful is is important and I think
you get a different level of
collaboration engagement when people
feel that you genuinely and
authentically care about them and their
well-being and and see them for more
than just the value to add company so I
believe a hundred percent in terms of
transparency of goals and creating very
clearly articulated goals for each
member of my team and having very high
expectations for people accomplishing
those goals and I don't have a lot of
leniency for not accomplishing those
goals that doesn't mean I'm not nice
about it but I think it's it's much
easier to be nice when you also sort of
created clear roles and designations for
people to work in a company then it's
not there's no there shouldn't be much
of a disconnect when people are failing
to live up to expectations well I think
attention to detail is critical when
you're developing projects at the
caliber that we are and Holborn is
exceptional in this regard the attention
to detail I mean we were walking through
the project today and the stuff we were
debating most people wouldn't believe
that they come on with a you know 360
million dollar project are you really
talking about these things but it's it's
it's that level of interest it's that
passion it's that energy and its really
that last 5% that makes something
exceptional you can build something
great but it could have been amazing
phenomenal the best if somebody had
really cared about that last 5% and and
I've seen this time and time again as a
personality trait in Zhu Kim and you
can't you can't fake that you either
really love what you're doing and you're
deeply passionate about your vision or
you'll let somebody else deal with the
5% and assume that those they may or may
not figure it out sometimes being a
negotiator is knowing you're not the
best person to negotiate if somebody
won't respond favorably to you you're
not serving your own interest by you
know continuing that line of dialogue
and that's why you know my brothers and
I work so well together there's certain
people I do much better with and
sometimes being a woman is is an
advantage you take people off guard I
use a new employee no charms to disarm
people no not female J well maybe no but
you know when somebody is either
unprepared expecting less of you I think
that's a great advantage so you know I
think about that a lot of people say
does it bother you when people
underestimate you and I say I welcome
people to underestimate me no I think
the key for
and successful preparation is it really
getting to dr. marell I think confidence
is so critical and so much of warm
success Walter negotiating probably for
themselves how they presented material
and to conviction in which they relay
their viewpoint so preparation is
everything if nothing else the quickly
the vast Association if you're well
researched and you know what you're
talking about much harder for somebody
to argue against your viewpoint so I
like to go into making communication
really
my fact really being up to speed I
founded it some incredible competitive
advantage I actually find that as people
get more successful and of doing a
little bit less work if they have people
under them who are doing some of the
l'amore research and a lot of that
information commute into them so
sometimes it's actually an advantage
when you're younger a little less
experience to negotiate with somebody
who's more formidable because a lot of
times they're not quite as up to speed
up on the competition you are but
preparation is incredibly important
amenity is taking a deep breath I think
when you're prepared you can feel a lot
more confident but you know I see people
waiting to go into a really important
meeting whether it's a job interview or
an important transaction negotiation and
they're sitting in the waiting room with
a hunched over there on their iPhone and
they're checking Instagram and I think
one of the more important things
set up straight read deeply to better
ourselves for a second and then process
out I think they're pretty important I
want my daughter Arabella to grow up
thinking that the phrase working woman
sounds as odd and superficial and forth
as the phrase working man my husband is
my greatest source of motivation she
always has it in her to accomplish
whatever she puts her mind to
he's the person I mean on the most I
always tell folks don't worry about the
things you can't control just worry
about how you react to and deal with the
circumstances situations at hand in the
moment that highest anxiety for me I
will think about Jerry and the kids and
realize that no matter how poorly I
perform I will come home that night and
my kids will not love me any less and my
husband will love me just as much maybe
even a little bit more because more
you'll know I'll need it shut our house
the way I purchase offer Wow you're
concerned about your reputation because
someone like you would be in the
spotlight given half the chance of the
media it could be in your house and in
your business all of the time so does it
concern you what you thought you see on
social media or what people write about
you or or Twitter or anything like that
I think you know early on I developed
quite a callus to the opinions of others
ultimately you know I I live in a way
that I would never want my children to
be embarrassed if something their mother
did so you know first and foremost I am
you know hopefully not doing things that
would be all that interesting to to
somebody from from a scandal perspective
um but you know I think I think you just
have to at some point you just have to
live and you have to drown out the noise
you know I grew up in a climate where
you know from when I was 14 years old
people would say well you know I I
wonder what she would ever accomplish if
it wasn't for her last name and you know
would she ever be able - OH - to achieve
great things if she didn't have to name
Trump and the reality is there's no
point fighting that because I myself
don't have an answer I know I was given
a tremendous advantage I have a name
that is globally recognized but it's
what I do with that and and you know
it's how hard I work in my own life so
you know fighting that is is a zero-sum
game
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Brenda Whiteman
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what did you learn
today from Ivanka that has the biggest
impact on you on your life on your
business were you immediately going to
do to make a change to make your life or
business better leave in the comments
below
I'm going to join in the discussion I
also want to give a quick shout to Noah
Sachs Noah thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book your one word and
doing that awesome review on your
YouTube channel I really really really
really appreciate it this book really
focuses on one core principle throughout
in terms of developing your one word or
your guiding idea that should be in the
forefront of every business decision and
branding decision you make thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love ceases
when I look at my friends have been
incredibly successful entrepreneurs
obviously you have to have an idea and
it has to be a good one
timing may be even more important than
than the idea because many great ideas
has been too early they've been too late
or they I'm about at the wrong time in a
cycle that really renders everything
else irrelevant you have to be supported
by an incredibly strong team so you know
a lot of entrepreneurs talk about how
lonely it is because they're making
decisions by themselves and really
spearheading the drugs as an
organization but you're not you're not
alone you have a team and you have to
build sort of a family around you they
can support and and align with
ultimately the vision you said and and I
think for me it's about understanding
where I can uniquely add value
understanding what I'm really good at
versus capable at versus not so good at
and making sure that I have the right
bench to fill in and those lower ends of
the spectrum and and seeing being a
young person myself it's that sometimes
the challenge because through trial in
there you learn where you excel
and where your core competency is how
would you keep your energy level high
coffee I caffeinate a lot of it but you
know meditation is actually really
helpful for me so when I can do it and
what I'm disciplined about doing it I do
find it helps my planner G and increase
my productivity and exercise I find that
when I run I feel great and I'm
exhausted for 10 seconds and it's like
my energy throughout the courses that I
don't do enough of that boosting that
but it is a helpful boost when I'm able
you know each day looks very very
different and truthfully that's part of
what I'm I'm so passionate about I think
more than being a developer more than
having my own fashion brand I think of
myself as an entrepreneur who keeps my
eye open for exciting opportunities and
and you have to have bandwidth in your
schedule despite how busy you are you
have to have a little bit of space to be
able to take that meeting that's not as
strategically relevant to everything on
your plate so it is important to be
surrounded by by people that you trust
and and it's important to spend your
time wisely to enable you to that fine
next opportunity